mark
ciao
indeed everybody's checking in on the
chat apparently
it's great
orlaco from Ghana welcome
you soon
but again
we'll start in just under three minutes
foreign
once again welcome to everyone
I'm starting in just about a minute so
okay
the clock is counting down
foreign
close enough let's get started
recording in progress
our presentation now
all right
and welcome to everyone
or a live look at the postgraduate
program in devops we'll be talking about
uh program from Caltech ctme the center
for technology and management education
in partnership with IBM and simply learn
I'm Stuart Creek I'm with simply learned
we're our the delivery partner with
Caltech for this program
talking about that I'll be um also
letting you hear from one of our expert
instructors I should talk uh bukhari
um
we're going to be asking a few questions
about you along the ways with some polls
so keep an eye out for those
um they'll be asking about or telling
you about devops careers and discussing
that a bit
uh we'll talk about how this
postgraduate program helps you succeed
and get prepared to be job ready in the
devops field
we'll cover some of the learner outcomes
we'll share with you how to enroll I'll
take some of your questions toward the
end so if you have questions that come
up along the way please put those in the
Q a
function of Zoom
and I will get to those toward the end
though about careers and devops um
the devops is transforming how software
is made
from
early days of computing
programs were considered to be fairly
static
we would spend a lot of time
in fact I personally used to punch decks
of paper Punch Cards
submit
jobs when I was a student
and you had to invest a lot of time into
making sure that everything was as you
needed it to be before you started
running it as
amount of time and effort to change
things
was
very costly
and so
if you had bugs in the program it was
not worth just fixing one bug and then
re-releasing you'd want it
put together a bunch of bug fixes and
releases on a periodic schedule
and that was how software worked and
the good old days of mainframes and many
computers
early days of personal computers today
it's a continuous process nobody wants
to wait around for a bug fix
and nobody wants to wait around for new
features
especially when your competitors are
introducing features and you have to
keep up so
devops drives this continuing process
for modern applications for web services
for mobile applications
it allows for shorter software
development life cycles
so that you can get to the next new
feature or the next fixed bug much
faster
continuous delivery so that
you don't have a
release cycle
that requires a big same day release of
software coordinated across all your
potential customers or existing
customers with a big release of
a new manual documentation change Pages
all of that
this process becomes now more seamless
more continuous more intuitive for the
the
user and the customer
and it allows you to make sure that the
software is of higher quality both
before you deliver it and
once you've delivered it to be able to
fix any issues that come up so
the market for devops services over four
billion dollars
and that's expected to Triple
a few years
um
this is a huge growing and
very important field
and devops skills can lead to a bunch of
different
career paths
the engineer an architect
um
go into quality and reliability aspects
you can
focus in on security with devsecops or
Cloud operations with devcloud Ops or
even how AI interacts with the devops
cycle you have ai Ops a number of
different paths these are all actual um
job titles look up on any of the job
boards and
uh
all start with the fundamentals of
devops and understanding
basics of the
principles of the devops cycle
so
you need to be up to date in the skills
to drive that devops career to start in
it and to move it forward
you need to understand the the
methodology
and the principles of continuous
integration and continuous delivery
um how devops is used for configuration
management
containerization
devops interactions with the cloud
because that's
the environment that makes devops
possible for Universal and continuous
deployment and delivery
you need to understand how devops
interacts with Source control and making
sure that
or
your code base is stable and
controlled
to understand the principles of
automating
the devops cycle and you need to
understand the cloud platforms on which
it operates all of these
skills together
Drive devops opportunities in front of
you
but with that I'm going to ask a
question or audience
you're all here because of your interest
in devops so what has stopped you up to
this point from
um
pursuing certification or education in
devops itself becoming a
devops expert
is it because you haven't found a
program that has that kind of
comprehensive curriculum that covers all
the skills
um because you worry that you wouldn't
get a practical experience from a
program that you could then
show off to a potential employer
because programs you've looked at are
all self-study self-paced videos that
really don't fit your learning style
or is it because you haven't found
time in your your own schedule to do
this type of work
let this uh continue on for about
another 10 seconds as you can get your
answers in please do that
I will
close the poll in five
four
three
two
[Music]
one
actually still still see some numbers
changing so I'll give you another few
seconds
just get those answers in
and I'll close the poll now
so the major concern in this audience is
is not getting uh practical experience
that you can show off to potential
employers once you finish the training
um certification
then finding a comprehensive uh
program and
finding time in your work scheduler are
also major concerns here so
share the results make sure you get a
chance to see that
and
let's talk a little bit about this
program and how it works
um first off the postgraduate program in
devops offered from Caltech
Center for technology and management
education again it's a partnership
uh IBM and
with simply learn we are the delivery
partner we provide the platform
and administration for the program
and
it's a comprehensive curriculum we'll
get into that in a few moments
um it's based on caltech's interaction
with industry and understanding what
employers come to them for
what skills
they demand from
graduates of Caltech programs like this
it contains integrated labs and Hands-On
projects that are all delivered on the
same online platform
don't need to have a separate
environment you just have a desktop or
laptop with a web browser
um
I can access much of the material on
your mobile device as you're studying
and you have 24.7 access to it so
other than the online live virtual
classes which are held
um on the weekends four hours on
Saturday for our Sunday
you have all the rest of the week on
your own schedule to do the rest of the
work projects tests assessments
pre-study of recorded materials
reviewing recordings of the classes
so in the online live virtual classrooms
you interact with your peers your
instructors
and you can ask your questions live of
the instructor so
um
you have all that available to you in a
single environment we'll show you that
in a bit
the end of it all you receive a
certificate from Caltech
that attests the fact that you've
completed the postgraduate program
uh that the
successfully completed all the core
courses
you will receive up to 25 continuing
education units for the amount of work
you've done and continuing education
units are important to folks who need to
show to employers or to licensing bodies
of government that you have kept up your
skills with continuing education so
that's a valuable
benefit of the program
you receive membership in a online
Caltech Circle which is a
group alumni of the Caltech ctme
programs allows you to do the industry
networking with other people who have
gone through similar programs and people
who've gone through the same program as
you and you get recognized that an
online convocation where you can invite
friends and family to
see you
individually called out for your
achievements
these are all the results of the program
and offered by Caltech and
you are not familiar with Caltech
um
maybe you're familiar with an American
situation comedy television program
called The Big Bang Theory the reason
they said it at the Caltech in Pasadena
California is because
of all the places in the world where uh
people do Advanced research and the best
and brightest gather that purpose
Caltech is one of the very top
consistently ranks on the top five
universities worldwide
has produced a number of Nobel laureates
many of the Nobel Prize winners
came from Caltech where they did the
research or won their Nobel prizes for
research elsewhere
now our working research at Caltech
uh
it's a fantastic Institution
been around for 130 years it is
a privately run institution not not run
by the state of California
and
having that name on your
CV or your resume is
definitely a prestigious accomplishment
people were working as that name so
we're very proud to be their delivery
partner here at simply learn
we're very very proud also to to bring
in the connection to IBM so through this
program there will be a number of
elective courses
that'll um you can take
uh at no additional cost
will be uh taught by IBM instructors
you're also master classes uh give you
an overview of
uh topics in the industry and in transit
industry from IBM lecturers
you have asked me anything in hackathon
sessions that you'll be able to access
so our
connection to IBM is
something we're very proud of because it
gives you a
look into
industry
people who are working in the industry
gives you a great perspective on that
great opportunity
um so I'm going to ask this point I'm
going to share with you some remarks
ashitosh made about
eligibility qualifications and what it
takes to be successful in this program
oh
um to do that
we talk about this program
and ashitosh what have you you found in
terms of
the backgrounds of people who have
successfully entered and completed this
program
this is a pretty accurate profile in
terms of the people coming in with a
non-programming background
maybe not having work experience can
they still
succeed at this program
yeah 100 because uh the way how calte
can simply learn designed uh the entire
devops program what I see is uh it is
taking you from a scratch even if there
is a person who has a little background
in a a little experience maybe probably
one or two years experience in the Linux
as administrator uh and he he might not
have any development background still he
can easily do this program uh because
you think by Celtic and simply learn
those are very helpful for those kind of
audience uh especially let's say about
Jenkins or git right most of the
non-programmer people has a mindset that
I should have a programming background
to learn Jenkins circuit but I can see
uh in few of my last classes I remember
around 70 percent of the audience was
a non programmer or non-programming
background so and that that doesn't
affect any of their performance and any
of their understanding stuff and again
even if freshers are there I think we
have Linux refresher course for them and
so I think at the end of the day the way
the content has been designed and the
curriculum is getting delivered with the
live instructors uh anyone who has no
background of programming or no work
experience can easily complete this
devops program uh without any
hurdles
great and this is one of the reasons why
we require a bachelor's degree because
with the bachelor's degree what you've
shown is that you can remain committed
to a program and see it through to the
end and succeed at it and if you have
that basic skill the other technical
aspects are things that we can help you
develop along the way in the program so
really this is intended for people again
from any background who have a
bachelor's degree and want to get into
devops as a a career
here
area I'm going to ask another poll
question
I hope my screen is visible
yep and we're looking at the
the postgraduate program and devops let
me
take it back so yeah this is uh one of
the first login screen what every
Learners will get
I think that's that is one of the unique
Point what uh simply learn and Caltech
is offering uh every learner is getting
an exclusive LMS access uh you will able
to see these kind of uh courses right
from the devops orientation to devops
certification get GitHub CI CD these are
the Technology based courses so I am
trying to take you to one of the course
just to show you how the labs and how
the Learners can take the advantage of
this entire LMS portal right so I'm just
going to take you to configuration
management with ansible and terraform
uh so the moment you logged into the
screen there are a couple of options you
can see here on the left side of this
LMS portal you have self learning option
uh where you can go through of course
this this specifically this course
doesn't have uh the recorded session the
live class curriculum is not here but
yeah other courses do have those things
uh but yeah you can download the ebooks
the PDFs the practice exercise I will
show you them separately I have
downloaded it already just to save the
time but yeah every learner will able to
get these ebooks and the practice Labs
then we have uh live classes where you
can see the recordings I think again
that's one of the uh
excellent advantage of having the LMS
with us you can get the recorded session
the previous class recorded session uh
from this place up
and yes ultimately you get a practice
lab access so you will get you will be
getting a AWS account uh where you can
try to launch an ec2 instance try to
create a VPC and then you can try to
automate using ansible or terraform uh
maybe infrastructure as a code here you
will be getting a separate AWS account
so this integration is very excellent uh
for uh and very excellent help for the
learners so that you don't need a AWS uh
free tier account or you know most of
the classes uh for most of the uh
training institutes are saying that you
need to have a credit card to access the
awsc I could able to access my AWS
account via simply learn LMS stuff this
integration is uh I personally if you
ask me I like this sort of integration
because you don't need anything as long
as you can take the advantage of all the
resources and then yes
even despite of this simply learn had
given
the
multi-host Labs or multi-node Labs
because if you talk about ansible I'm
just taking example if you talk about
I'm ansible you need to configure at
least two or three nodes so you need
multiple resources so to deploy that on
a AWS may take time right so uh in place
of that you have C you have an excellent
uh
terminal axis for these three machines
so you have one controller you can
configure these machines for uh your
managed host one manage host two I think
similar sort of lab is available in your
Docker and kubernetes as well so when
you try to
set up a multi-tier application or
sorry multi-node cluster right so when
you say multi-node cluster you have to
have at least two or three uh nodes or
virtual machines right so the similar
kind of lab is there in kubernetes also
so you don't need to uh try minicube
right most of uh the Learners commonly
ask me a question as a trainer like
ashitosh are we going to set up a mini
Cube server because it's just a
simulator it's it's not the actual uh
what I can say kubernetes cluster right
but here in this uh simply learn and
Caltech course you will able to learn
how to deploy the actual kubernetes
cluster right even not only kubernetes I
think Jenkins get then configuration
management right you talk about Docker
whatever all these things comprises of
this sort of lab that gives a trainer as
a trainer also a a very uh
kind confidence
and even the learner will get a
confidence that oh I'm not only able to
understand the theory behind the uh all
the logical aspect but I could able to
perform the Hands-On and I I actually
know the technology right because you
know in this uh current disruptive word
you should know how things work
practically as well right because Theory
you can get it from anywhere nowadays
right but you should know and even that
that encourage a trainer to show you
more than extended stuff right so I
usually uh
uh L my Learners try to try to do these
things which might not be in the content
maybe after the class maybe some
Enterprise grade Solutions these things
are very helpful just because of these
labs like so I'm I'm completely
impressed uh since the beginning like
I'm doing uh these sort of training for
simply learn from so many years so when
I saw this first time I said oh wow man
I will be enjoying my training
deliveries also right so that's one of
the uh very logical stuff and last uh
but not the least again uh every course
comprises of uh the uh projects the end
project or course end project is there
so you can see on screen that yes it is
talking about a project which you need
to submit right like a automation using
ansible a CI CD or deploy a WordPress
environment so you have to submit this
and then uh of course you will get a
certificate unlock
right so that is more uh
a convenient and that is more uh
appealing for the end user or the
Learners that oh I completed my course
but within this time frame I have to
submit my assignment also or I have to
submit my project also right so that
that's how the entire uh
LMS works and what sort of slides you
will be getting I could quickly take you
through one of the course I'm so sorry
my I have so many things downloaded uh
but yeah I can quickly go to one off
yeah I'm taking you for the cka uh PG
PDF courses intentionally because I
talked about and see Bill or CMT program
so here you can see that these are the
slides which not only talk about
theoretical stuff but you will able to
get in and out of all the Practical
approach yourself each of them had some
practice assignment also let me check if
I can show you that also
so
yeah I have something called assistant
practice C so if you see these kind of
assisted practice practices are very
helpful for the Learners where they can
actually see how it works in a
step-by-step manner with these
screenshots right so even in the class
even after the class learner has an
option a very great option to try this
in a in all aspects right what else a
learner need right so you get a live
training you get a demo from a trainer
you are getting a slides you are able to
perform it and you are able to see
or you are able to get the step by step
commands to deploy such kind of things
right so these are you can see in on my
screen
all lessons have assisted practice and
around every lesson so I think
in a numbers I could say around 45 plus
practice sessions would be there this is
just the approx number guys uh maybe
this may vary depending on your course
but if you talk about cka so I believe
minimum 45 plus
assisted practices has been there for
the Learners right and even of course
your trainer might give you some uh
logical uh discussion of or how all
these things work
so that's the logic behind your LMS and
uh
that's that's how the labs works
over to used one
thank you very much I appreciate that uh
um can you by the way mention
um what happens when people reach a
doubt or a blocker and
want to uh get help with that between
classes that type of thing
so uh let's see uh if you face any
difficulty in the course or in the class
so we have an excellent uh resource uh
here I forgot to
show you that about the community so we
have an excellent initiative uh where
simply learned Community is there so you
can basically
go to this post your question and peers
from your uh class or maybe from
Community or trainers like me will be
basically uh helping you to do that and
if you if you have any technical glitch
let's say due to some issue I am not
able to log into my lab then we have
excellent helpline support here you can
raise a ticket right uh and trust me uh
our support team is very proactive I
would not say active they are very
proactive in all aspects they will
usually reply you quickly and they will
try to sort out or help you uh while uh
getting this work so that's that's the
logic behind the technical support
wonderful thank you very much so I'm
going to uh
return to our presentation and I will
take back the screen sharing peace
all right and you've seen
um
just recap what ashita shared with you
how to manage your curriculum uh how the
system guides you through a series of
courses live virtual classroom
environment to take tests and
assessments do your projects
I will talk about the Capstone project
as part of this curriculum
and how the system keeps track of your
progress gives you certificates for each
courses you complete it and then the
overall certificate at the end of the
program
talked about the support tools including
the community the 24 7 help desk
so all of that is there to keep you on
track and successful
the program builds your devops skills
step by step so
uh start off with an orientation session
which is just basically
reviewing what the curriculum will
contain how to use the learning
management system
and getting you all set up and then you
move into your first real class which is
certification training for devops at the
end of that class you'll be able to take
a a basic certification test that will
get you uh First Step along the way
then you'll move into
learning how to use ansible and
terraform for configuration management
after that you'll become Docker
certified through the next course
be able to then take
container orchestration using cubanities
and finally you will do a Capstone
project that ties all of these skills
that you've learned together
um requires you to demonstrate that you
can use them all to solve a industry
aligned problem we'll talk about that a
little bit more but once you've done the
Capstone project and that's been
graded you will be awarded your
certificate now along the way you are
able to take elective courses
at your discretion so you can choose to
take any or all of them
based on your
level of interest in your time
availability and these are all at no
extra cost so these include the the
devops master classes from Caltech C
team instructors from the IBM
instructors
and you can also study
statistics for data science you can look
at NLP and speech recognition which are
topics in machine learning artificial
intelligence you can go into
looking into Jenkins CDs CI and CD
pipeline operations get training in git
and GitHub if you need that
and you can learn about the cloud
aspects of devops so all of those things
are available to you as electives
program as well
I'm going to ask
for one last time for
share with you uh some of ashitasha's
comments on the tools
that you'll be learning how to use so
that
yeah for sure so uh I think uh you know
there are few courses uh right from git
yes of course so uh I would take it in a
different manner so at Stuart to answer
this it the devops program what we have
it covers what you need to
do a Justice with application deployment
that is CI CD because your application
deployment needs a CI CD continuous
integration and the continuous delivery
and or a deployment right so right from
get Jenkins we have Docker we have AWS
covered we have maybe elective I might
not have a great knowledge on the
elective subjects but I'm just taking
those Technologies in the ecosystem then
we have for sure
kubernetes which is an orchestration uh
tool and in a back-end of course you
should have a Docker knowledge a
container management knowledge without
which you cannot deal with the
orchestration stuff so of course Docker
is there kubernetes is there then we
have uh you have to orchestrate or you
have to automate this stuff so for that
we have ansible which is a configuration
management Tool uh in the current
ecosystem so that helps you to prepare
for uh deploying the AWS instances or
rather deploying the application in a
broader way in a production scenario
that's sensible for us and then we need
to deploy maybe Cloud instances on Azure
or on our AWS right so for that we have
something called
uh terraform right so as a terraform uh
infrastructure as a code you will be
using it and deploying it on top of uh
the uh AWS account or maybe Azure
account whatever you need so it as I
said it covers right from the code what
you have in a git or GitHub maybe any
SVN control system till the infra or
till the application diploma so it
covers uh all the aspect and of course
you need to have a build tool which is
Jenkins in a backend you should have a
testing tool like a mavian or a junit
test you will be writing a test you will
be testing all those ecosystem you need
a report of all this you need to write a
pipeline so all these things can be
easily uh doable using something called
Jenkins so it covers most of the or all
of the disruptive Technologies uh
in and out knowledge what you need uh in
the current ID standard
yeah overtures
and thank you very much for that
we talk about this program
okay
so you've heard about the different
tools that you will use and it's not a
matter of you get exposed to them or you
find out how they work you have to use
them
on real world aligned projects here are
some examples of things you might
do in the program
Jenkins Pipeline and the branching
development model for
um
work integration on multiple development
streams
um
containerizing with docker
all the different types of aspects of
modern
software development in the devops
environment ecosystem and then how to
make it work so
these are all Hands-On projects you'll
do and um
you'll pick for the end of the program a
Capstone project
you'll pick a one based on your
preference of what problem appeals to
you it'll be a defined problem
of of a real world industry aligned type
and you'll have three to four weeks to
work with your instructor on it you'll
meet the instructor weekly they'll make
sure that you're staying on track and
not
reaching any blockers or doubts along
the way but
um once you have completed this project
and built Your solution to the problem
that'll be something that not only gets
graded for
earning your certificate in this program
but it's something you can take with you
in your portfolio
permanently so that you can show that
off
to Future employers or to your current
employer and demonstrate that yes you
have these new skills and you know how
to use them so Capstone project we think
sorry is a very important aspect of this
program
the program is a
under the auspices of Caltech ctme it's
it's overseen by Rick Hefner Matthew
dartez Eugene Lai who are all both
academic and industry experienced
people who have many years of experience
see Rick has been in industry in
academics for 40 years Eugene's been
doing this type of work for 20 years
um Matthew deals with software
development and devops as well so
these are the people who oversee the
curriculum and make sure that it's being
delivered to you
to get you the
skills that you need to succeed as a
devops expert
now we can talk a little bit about
learner outcomes
so these are where people come from in
the program
um people come from information
technology and software certainly but
also from banking telecommunications
financial and other Industries because
nearly every industry relies on
deploying software
um
applications
whether they're for internal use or
whether they're customer facing
and devops is the way that this is done
in the modern world so nearly every
industry nearly every company needs
this type of help
that's why you see people come to the
program from Amazon Microsoft
emphasis IBM JP Morgan
Accenture Oracle
Bosch the automotive parts company
um
Wells Fargo Bank
so you'll be
studying alongside people from a wide
variety of backgrounds and a lot of
cross fertilization of your career can
happen when you
are working alongside your peers in the
course
here are some learner reviews
pardon me
uh I'll give you a chance to read these
from Milan from chance
from Manuel
um but all of them went through this
particular program with Caltech and
simply learn
and uh
achieved
really good results Manuel in particular
achieved a 21 salary hike because of
this course we're able to earn a
promotion from it so
um
we have a number of these stories that
we can share with you
at this point I just want to ask a quick
question
are you interested
in enrolling in this program
watch this poll
it's based on what you know so far
leave this open for about uh
15 more seconds
I will close the poll in about five
seconds get your answers in please
and
here's the result 85 percent of our
audience today responded Yes so that's
fantastic
I do want to mention one aspect of this
as we get into the enrollment
shared those results
flash those again
and
um
one aspect of the program services that
I did not mention but I think is
important to know is that if you are a
Learner in India
um
this program includes
um career assistance services
through our partner IAM jobs
something that's run by simply learn
extends for six months after you earn
your certificate and it helps you with
things like resume development interview
prep and job search so this is not a job
guarantee program it doesn't guarantee
that you will find a job but it does
help you with your job search so
another benefit of the program
uh enrollment steps
uh you start off by sending an uh email
to us here at ask us at simplywin.net
because we are the administrative and
delivery partner with Caltech
um work with Caltech
to review your qualifications verify
your educational background
um
give you a simple test to make to assess
where you are in terms of having basic
programming skills
again you do not have to have those in
order to succeed in this program but we
just like to do the assessment to get
idea of
where you are and how much help you'll
need and then we'll send you your
admission offer presuming you meet all
the requirements our next
induction
15th of February so you can start right
away
um the classes
the actual live classes start on the 4th
of March
and the cost of this program depends
nominated differently depending on where
you are if you are in India the cost is
one lock thirty three thousand inclusive
of taxes and
you can get interest to free or zero
cost financing for as little as 4415
rupee a month
which
allows you to pay this off over time get
started
without having to put down the entire
amount up front if you are elsewhere in
the world
North America or anywhere else in the
world outside of India the course is
denominated in US dollars
the total cost is four thousand eight
hundred forty nine dollars again you can
receive
financing zero cost financing for 427 a
month
which I believe works out to be a
12-month payment program
and
if you uh
have an employer who offers tuition
reimbursement you should check to see
they have that benefit for you some
employers do that would be your lawyer's
policy but if they do you can check to
see if they'll help you defray some of
this cost
and in the meantime reach out to us at
ask us simply learn.net um we'll get you
the information you need to get started
help you with the enrollment application
answer any final questions you may have
um so
at this point I'd like to ask for those
of you who said you're interested and
now that you know the cost
um
how soon would you be interested in
starting the program how soon do you
plan to start are you
planning to apply immediately and get
into that induction class the day after
tomorrow
um are you looking a little bit further
down the road
let this run for about another 15
seconds
please do get your answers in
I'll close it in five four three
two one in the pole
and
more than 40 percent of our audience
wants to start either in the March
classes or the ones in April and May
which is great if you're looking to go
further out
um
to Future
editions the class or the course please
contact us and ask us at simplylearn.net
we will answer any questions you have
and we will make sure that we stay in
formed about future conditions of the
program as well so
but this is very encouraging to see
people who are wanting to start right
away at this point I'm going to try to
answer your questions
who again apologize for not being able
to address any of those up till now
we're looking mainly in the Q a so if
you put a question in the chat uh it
would be helpful if you would repost
that into the Q a
to put that over here
from where can we start with like which
language of programming so
um
devops
doesn't rely so much on the programming
language as the
scripting tools but um
you will be able to practice your
project I'll look
um through the online environment you'll
be able to
go through all of the particular tools
that are being used
and you'll receive instruction in
programming languages that you'll need
to use those tools and configure your um
your projects so
will you provide a certificate for this
webinar I'll I'll share that with you
Gotham on how to how to ask for that
um
what is the roadmap of devops and how is
it useful to learn as a fresher
but honestly I hope we've covered the
road map in the
um
curriculum
stair step that I shared with you
um and
the important thing to understand
if you are
getting into software development in any
capacity
you're probably going to have to
interact with the devops environment so
having the understanding of it is going
to help you as a developer but it also
opens up a bunch of career opportunities
for you to work in and operate the
devops environment
anonymous
attendee who asks how will it be helpful
for someone with around 10 years of I.T
experience but no devops background
switch into this career so again if you
are an i.tit Administration
this becomes a new opportunity for you
to move into
the development side
and
uh devops really
is the the future of software
development so if you're looking at
maybe making that transition and moving
into more
um
kind of real-time side of of
applications development this is an
excellent program for that
okay
Santos says I could not complete my
degree studies due to financial
challenges
I've been pursuing uh open source
training qualifications
can I be Exempted from the degree uh
requirement
um
I can't say that
um but you would want to contact the
Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net
and ask them that question and see
whether or not there's a way for you to
test out of that requirement or
demonstrate through your background that
you've met all of the
technical aspects of prerequisites but
generally speaking this is a
postgraduate program and we're very
kind of strict on that again contact us
and find out if this uh if you have the
ability to access this program or if
there are other options that we can
offer you
uh is there a trial period to test I
would ask that of the of the learning
Consultants as well
um generally speaking I don't believe so
but there are other resources that we
have that would allow you to do some
looking at the program before you start
um
do we give any career opportunities for
juniors or trainees and devops we do not
give those but we do offer the
job search support for those
so that's
all the questions I've probably covered
which devops tools are must to learn
and from that tools discussion that um
ashutosh had
you can understand that it's important
to learn
the kind of spectrum of tools because
they all work together for different
aspects of devops so it's very difficult
to um
say you have to pick you you're going to
pick one or the other you really want to
have that broad background which is why
we developed the program this way
so but ansible Jenkins kubernetes docker
get all of those tools are vital
um how many live projects do we get I
think uh I should tell us talked about
that but there's
dozens of live projects within this
premiere
um
Shailesh if you want to ask a question I
think you do need to type it into the uh
uh
looking at how does devops managing
different
languages Frameworks hosting services
in the same company and how can a
non-programming
background person handle these
activities
this is a great question which is um
how devops manages these different items
is
fundamentally through
the containerization process where
um
software is turned into
pieces that can be assembled and
deployed
in an automated fashion
um
and and become interoperable among
different
platforms and different languages and
that type of thing so that's one aspect
of that and you learn about that in this
program and then the other how can a
non-programming background person handle
these activities you'll
learn how these different pieces work
together and how to
configure them
so that they work together any
programming
um
capability that you need to succeed in
the program we can train you in during
the program itself
um
covered the academic requirement of
a little second
um
the scholarship you would ask ask us at
simplylearn.net to find out whether
there is uh any scholarship available
um
online live classes
four hour split are we able to focus and
grasp within four hours in a single go
the way that we've organized the classes
and the way that we run them
um probably they
yes our students are able to stay
focused and engaged during the class
because it's not a
a four hour you're just watching the
lecture we're just watching a video it
is interactive and your instructor is
taking you through the material and
asking you questions as well and letting
you ask questions
and taking you through exercises and
showing you how to do it so
it's not
um like watching a four hour movie
a four-hour seminar each time so
can I relate security with devops
oh yes you can
um and part of the the course we'll
touch on devsecops which is the
way that security is integrated into the
devops lifecycle
um
all right so uh
although I say says uh how easy will it
be for me if I've got Azure
certification
on switching to Cloud devops engineering
you're Azure certified
um you have a foundation that will help
you understand
um the environment in which devops
operates so uh
you should have a really good foundation
for for this course succeeding
uh
bumsy asks is the future with devops
greater or less opportunity if you have
no experience well again
this program is intended to take someone
with no experience and move them into
capability to work in devops and then
from that you have the opportunity to
continue
um developing your skills moving up your
career letter
so your opportunities are
are very good once you have
this Foundation
how long does it take to complete course
leave this as an 11 month course let me
double check that
just a moment and a quick look
I think I shared that
the nine month course I'm sorry
misspoke it's a nine-month course
uh the classes are available on the
weekends for working professionals
that's exactly the way the program is
designed so that it fits into the
schedule for working professionals
um
maduri I would uh you have a technical
question that is beyond my ability to
answer so I would um
contact
learning consultants and they may be
able to point you to somebody who can
um
talk to you about your question about
ansible
node management
and we shared this recording you will
receive an email
after this session with a link to this
recording
uh
Josh asked if the certificate is that
recognized worldwide the the name of
Caltech is recognized worldwide you also
earn
um certifications along the way
and sort of certificates issued by IBM
as well as preparation for official
Certification testing and certain skills
devops so you have a number of
qualifications that are
um
internationally recognized
my Indian sir no sir I am not um but
simply learn is based in Bangalore so
um it's
Indian company that's been in business
for more than 10 years
yeah and we've trained over 5 million
people worldwide in different technology
skills so
uh
um
uh how is full stack development
different from devops Full stack
development of course
looks at the interaction of the
different levels of the stack from
database on up to the front end and how
software operates from the perspective
of
how it delivers functionality to the
user devops looks at how software is
deployed so that it can be presented to
the user for their for their use it's a
different
there are two aspects of
uh
software development both very important
um classes are available virtual and
offline so a number of these classes are
first off all the everything is
delivered online
ugly live classes are virtual
um do you need to plan to attend a
certain percentage of them you have to
really
go into this understanding that you're
going to devote your your weekends to it
uh you do have the chance to catch up if
you happen to miss a class or two but
um you do have an attendance
um requirement of a minimum percentage
and um
again those are all
delivered online in a live format so
you're interacting with the instructors
and your peers in your class
yes because this is a postgraduate class
generally speaking if you do not have a
bachelor's degree this program is not
particularly open
to you but um again contact us at ask us
at simplylearn.net ask that question
about what options we have
if you don't have a bachelor's degree
yeah I think we've reached their time
and all of the questions in the Q a so
I'm going to go ahead and move on
to our
closing question for you in the audience
one last question for you
won't bring it up on the screen but I
will bring it up in the widget
which is do you need assistance
to get
enrolled and for those of you who asked
about receiving a certificate for this
particular
webinar
please answer yes if you want to get a
certificate and we'll we'll send that
out to you
that'll be just a proof of attendance
certificate that you attended this
webinar but
if that's something something you would
like
we'll we'll
get that to you
I'll leave this open for another five
seconds
and
so
more than two-thirds of our respondents
said that they are interested
and if you answered yes we will send you
that
proof of attendance certificate by email
with that
I want to say thank you to everyone who
attended here today thank you all for
devoting your time this evening
um the QR code takes you to the program
page and I am also going to put that
into the
chat right now so that you can
get to the
program page
and
so that you have the email address your
fingertips
moment so I click that into the chat
and I'll give you a couple of seconds
to get those links out of the chat as
well
so again thank you everyone for being
here today
I want to express our appreciation and I
want to off offer you uh
our best wishes for you to join us here
in the simply learn and Caltech Learning
Community we hope to see you soon
and um hope to be able to help you get
started on a successful career in devops
uh with that
our
webinar has come to a close so thank you
so much